of the thousands of scripts submitted
only 12 become finalists and even though
five will become nickel fellows this
year being a finalist is in itself an
amazing achievement so I'd like to ask
the finalists here tonight to please
stand for a round of applause
[Music]
[Applause]
tonight marks the beginning of a year of
fellowship one where the winners right
over the writers whose work you see on
stage tonight will receive support
mentorship and most importantly access
access so their words and ideas can
reach audiences and screens everywhere
this year alone past Nikhil fellows have
worked on the following projects escape
room relive extremely wicked shockingly
evil and vile the kid Dumbo
Brian banks just mercy unbelievable Mary
for all mankind and that's just this
year a nickel fellowship can kick open a
door and offer that chance for a
talented writer to show what they can do
in fact our director for the read
tonight
Gita Malick is a past nickel fellow I
remember her winning script dinner with
friends a fun and insightful story about
an American in Indian American family
and everyone thought it was just ready
to go out and make so that's what she
did
this spring she wrote and directed her
feature film now called India sweets and
spices and it's finishing up in post
she is also running a pilot for Tristar
based on a young adult novel and she was
the first recipient of the Academy Gold
fellowship for women at 2018 has become
an inspiration for others to follow
she will be directing an amazing cast of
actors thank you to Tyrese Gibson Rosa
Salazar Amandla Stenberg and West Duty
for showing their support to the nickel
fellows tonight let's celebrate our
winners and their work and now Geeta
Malik will begin a read thank you